a Zelda game without bosses is like a
bowl of ramen with only noodles it's
like wait what you've heard this intro
before oh I see I used it in the last
video okay let me do something new a
Zelda game without bosses is like beef
stew with only beef in it there a
completely new intro anyway the point is
Zelda bosses are each special and
interesting and memorable and are a big
part of what makes the Zelda game so
spicy and in Twilight Princess there are
a ton of them and they're plenty spicy
after the awesome reception of the
bossler video I did on Ocarina of Time I
decided to go ahead and make this sequel
video explaining the lore behind all the
bosses in Twilight Princess and if you
missed the Ocarina of Time video no
worries it'll be linked in the
description below also I was helped by
the one and only law online historian
for several bosses in this video so a
huge thanks to him for his XL sized
input so here we go yeah and uh spoiler
alert obviously to start we're gonna go
over all of the bosses in the game that
were made through the power of the fused
Shadow which would Encompass the first
three dayababa from the Forest Temple
virus from the Goron mines and more more
fuel from the lake bed Temple Each of
which are pretty easy to explain as a
reminder or in case you've never played
the game the three main light spirits in
the game were responsible for sealing
away the powerful dark magic that The
Interlopers created in order to spite
the gods see the goddesses themselves
weren't the biggest fans of this idea so
they had the Light Spirit seal the magic
away in the fused Shadow relics which
were then each hidden within the
aforementioned temples except for the
one that midno wears on her head she
just kind of has that one when we meet
her which she got at some point after
being turned into an imp we don't really
know where she got it maybe The
Interlopers took one with them when they
were banished through the mirror into
the Twilight realm but hey at least it's
conveniently the perfect fit for her imp
sized Cranium anyway the three fused
Shadows that were placed within the
temples kind of ended up corrupting
whatever life forms they came in contact
with which is what fused Shadows do
according to lederu since they're
essentially made of dark magic the first
boss in the game dayababa is actually
just a Deku Baba you know one of these
plants these really annoying plants it's
clear from the giant decubaba heads and
the name Baba in Daya Baba that it was
indeed a corrupted Deku Baba and now
I've said Deku Baba too many times and
it doesn't sound real moving on virus
from the Goron mines is actually the
patriarch of the gorons who had entered
the mine in order to figure out why the
volcano was acting so weird Darvis
apparently came into contact with the
fused Shadow once entering the volcano
and boom evil transformation fortunately
links many stabs from his sword didn't
actually kill him it just beat the evil
out of him and he soon returned to
normal right after not remembering
anything of the affair the boss of the
water temple I mean the lake bed Temple
more feel is once again a fused Shadow
corrupted eel which is evidenced by its
eel-like appearance and the word eel in
its name morpheal and it's not super
hard to believe that an eel was living
underwater so we'll call this one good
next let's move on to a very similar
kind of boss in the game those that were
corrupted by the pieces of the mirror of
twilight instead of the fused Shadow
which happens after Zant destroys the
mirror to preemptively prevent midna
from crossing over to the other side
since he was only able to break it into
four pieces one of which remained on the
mirror frame he needed some place to
hide hide them so he pulled a light
spirit's move and hid each piece within
a temple or mansion on top of a mountain
and speaking of a mansion on top of the
mountain the snow peak ruins is the
location of the first boss blizzetta
blizzetta is really just a little yeti
lady named Yeta who lives alone with her
husband appropriately named yeto and who
really likes her piece of the mirror of
twilight so much so that bam it corrupts
her and turns her into a monster and may
have even snapped her neck fortunately
you only really have to break the evil
ice she builds up around her leaving her
body unscathed after the fight and fit
for some husband and wife Lovin moving
on the next piece of the mirror is found
in the distant past of the Temple of
Time It's curious as to how Zant was
able to do this since the door of time
doesn't open in the game until link
places the master sword in its pedestal
once again something Zant would not have
been able to do but that's another
theory for another day the boss of the
Temple of time is the Twilight arachnid
armagoma who is literally just a giant
tarantula spider meaning the mirror
Shard must have corrupted a tarantula
spider in order to make armagoma and
sprout an evil eye on her back and we
know what to her because she makes lots
of babies this boss definitely gets
yeeded from existence though and once
sufficiently sent to the afterlife as
all spiders should be procures the
second mirror Shard the final Shard can
be found high in the sky in the city in
the sky inhabited by the strange Ooka
race of little chicken people anyway
these little chicken people were being
harassed by a dragon sent by Zant named
argarok the Twilight Dragon whose Aunt
created by corrupting one of the regular
car garak bird dinosaur enemies with the
final Shard of the mirror I'm not sure
if Zant meant for argurok to immediately
begin terrorizing the Uka people in the
sky or if he simply wanted to hide a
shard in the most mobile form he could
think of but either way link and midna
are able to locate and kill the Beastie
and thus reclaim the final mirror Shard
with the bosses made through both forms
of Twilight corruption out of the way
let's now shift our Focus to the bosses
that are just regular beings or monsters
in the world of Hyrule untainted by the
corruption of Twilight the first boss on
this list is the Caked Up baboon named
oog Who is the very first mini boss of
the game actually ook is the leader of
the tribe of keys that live in the
farron woods just outside ordona and is
normally just a regular funny monkey guy
until he got corrupted but no not by the
Twilight see ook somehow had a parasitic
bug latch onto his forehead which was
the reason he started to go insane in
the first place this parasitic bug has
designs that are similar to the goats of
aardon which my good buddy lanlon
historian astutely pointed out so it's
probably safe to say that this bug is
actually a natural parasite that just so
happened to latch onto ook maybe even
while the Cake Master was sleeping
either way once properly spanked ook
smashes into a nearby totem pole so hard
that it knocks the parasite off of his
head which ends up dying immediately
after detaching from its host kinda
makes you feel bad for mercilessly
destroying ook's ass when you could have
just knocked off the bug huh anyway next
up we have the Goron guard named Dan
Gora or as I like to call him Dan who we
meet in the Goron mines Dan's just a
good guy who's doing his job of
protecting the sacred treasure hidden
within the mines which is of course the
Hero's Bow Dan isn't really the
brightest though so instead of just
asking why link is there Dan jumped
straight to trying to murder him once
you dump Dan into the lava a couple
times Dan listens to your reasons for
being there and immediately goes back to
being friendly and lets you pass just an
ordinary Dan who jumped the gun a bit
too early next up we have the Deku Toad
from the lake bed Temple and honestly
this one is just as simple as its
wildlife of Hyrule that somehow made its
home in the temple underneath Lake hylia
and just so happened to move into the
room that just so happened to have the
claw shot inside it which the toad just
so happened to swallow I highly doubt
that there was some grand scheme from
the makers of the temple for the hero to
slice up a literal toad or rather the
Toad's tongue in order to regain the
sacred claw shot from its stomach acids
yeah pretty sure this one's just an
accident of nature anyway weird vomiting
and fibic enemies aside next up we have
the familiar skull kid from The Lost
Woods I mean the sacred grove it's my
opinion that this is the very same skull
kid as the skull kid from Ocarina of
Time in Majora's Mask because he knows
saria's song which the hero of time
taught to a particular Skull Kid hun
hundreds of years ago plus skull kids
are Immortal so it's definitely possible
but of course it's also possible that
it's just a different Skull Kid since
there are an unknown number of them
living in the woods and they could have
just heard the song The Skull Kid is a
childlike Forest Spirit who loves games
and mischief and who in this case forces
link to play with him before allowing
link access to the area deep within the
woods where the Temple of Time and
therefore the master sword rest but he's
not really a bad guy he's just the
fantasy version of it's a prank bro next
up is the dark Hammer from the
mysterious snow peak ruins now this is
definitely one of the more obscure
bosses in the game but I personally
subscribe to the notion that since the
snow peak ruins itself has strong ties
to the royal family of Hyrule and since
there are many cages and other dark
camera suits of armor present in the
ruins the dark Hammer must be the result
of some sort of experimental super
soldier that the royal family was trying
their best to procure it's not like they
haven't done some very similar very
shady War tactic things in the past
either case in point being the Shadow
Temple from Ocarina of Time and they do
also have some of their Knights use the
ball and chain weapon over in the the
Fallen timeline also it does make sense
that this dark Hammer would simply be
one of many due to the sheer number of
giant three-fingered suits of armor
present throughout the ruins so adding
this all together it's my interpretation
that the dark camera that link fights in
the game is a fragment of the ruins's
history which is that there were
experimental super soldiers created
possibly from the Liz alfos or dinolfo's
species and stored Within the Ruins one
of which was still alive and sprung to
life when link tried to pass through
this storage room but of course this is
all theoretical and if you personally
have a better theory that you'd rather
believe you are more than welcome to
believe that instead but I will say if
you're interested in the subject and you
want to learn more Celtic has a very
good theory video that sums up what I'm
trying to talk about I'll link to it the
description below moving on though the
next non-twilight boss would be the very
similar dark nut which is another giant
armor-clad enemy that's even more
intelligent and even more humanoid than
the dark Hammer now I have an entire
in-depth theory on The Dark Knight
enemies in general and how they link to
both the hero of time and the hero of
Twilight which I will link in the
description below again if you are
interested in a deeper dive into this
concept but in a nutshell it is again my
interpretation that the darknet knights
are none other than corrupted Knights of
Hyrule the biggest evidence being their
physical placements and the clear
loftwing symbology on not only their
Twilight Princess appearances but also
their Wind Waker appearance where
they're shown to flat out own night's
crests which again features a prominent
loftwing symbol and heavily emphasizes a
knight so yeah in a nutshell dark nuts
are corrupted Knights of Hyrule but for
more info check out my theory from 2020.
moving on the next natural boss in the
game is the aerophose which simply put
is another sword and shield wielding
humanoid lizard enemy just like the
lizel foes and dinofos who are also
similarly named except the aerofos as
Airborne with wings making them more
deadly and therefore more rare and also
like the little foes and Dino foes the
arrow foes serves the forces of evil
it's a long-running theory that all of
these lizard enemies are nothing more
than the creations of malisons are shown
to be made of malice in breath of the
wild which would technically mean that
they come from demise and are actually
demons but that's a separate theory for
the purposes of this video The Arrow
foes is just an another evil serving
lizard monster that seems to be guarding
the second Clash out the first time we
see it in the game perhaps trying to
prevent the hero from obtaining the
necessary item to complete the city in
the sky dungeon and therefore claim the
final mirror Shard and finally it's time
to talk about the most recurring boss in
the game king boblin or as I like to
call him Zelda Shrek this guy's
existence and purpose is described by
his name he's the king of the Baldwin
species of monsters and he even explains
why he and his people are so actively
trying to kill you of their own volition
he follows the strongest side simply put
he must have witnessed the power of Zant
at some point in the game and decided
that for the health and well-being of he
and his people if he wanted to survive
he should probably be on Zant's side but
after witnessing Link in his powerful
ABS decided to switch sides to the good
side nobody likes a bandwagoner but hey
at least he's honest the bigger question
here is where do the Baldwin species
originate from in the first place since
they've rarely made appearances outside
this game but personally I don't think
this matters much especially since they
also make an appearance in the adult
timeline in the game's spirit X meaning
they're out there in the world of Hyrule
and Beyond we just don't see them very
often some people believe that the
bulbens are none other than the evolved
Garuda women but uh yeah no I I don't
buy that personally especially because
according to the encyclopedia the Gerudo
had actually moved further into the
desert at this point explaining their
absence the Baldwins must have just bit
another species of monster just like
bakoblins or moblins or lionels or you
know all the other species of monsters
in the series oh and King Baldwin's
Mount also has a name Lord bulbo Lord of
all bull bows which are the giant pig
monsters that Baldwins ride on and
that's about it the last natural boss
we'll discuss before moving on to the
main character bosses is the one the
only the Twilight bloat this gorgeous
elegant creature has many similarities
to a queen termite another gorgeous
elegant creature their beauty is beyond
compare and just like the termite I
believe the Twilight bloat is the mother
of all the shadow insects their Queen if
you will which were created by Zant in
order to steal the light spirits's tears
of Twilight what a beautiful animal
species now with all the non-main
character bosses out of the way it's
time to focus on the two that started it
all Zant and the big man Ganondorf
himself but let's start with Zant and
with the Z had a job before he usurped
the Twilight throne in the Twilight
royal castle he was a helper of the
Twilight royal family who served them
because he believed that he would be the
next appointed to rule however to his
dismay when it came time to choose the
next leader it was midna who was chosen
instead of Zant because people could see
that he lusted for power and not much
else and she was then given the powers
that only the ruler of the Twilight can
possess now it's unknown if the Twilight
had a Royal bloodline like the Hylian
royal family has which would imply that
if midna and Zant are both up for the
crown that they would both be related or
if it's simply the matter of appointing
the next Monarch regardless of blood
relation either way Zant got a little
perturbed at this since after all he was
patient and tried to wait his turn and
in his desperation while he was
literally throwing a temper tantrum on a
balcony he lifted his eyes and saw a god
and this God had a name Ganondorf
Ganondorf vested part of his power which
is a mixture of dark Gerudo magic
stemming from his mother twin rova and
that of the Triforce of power in Zant
giving Zant much more power than that of
the simple ruler of Twilight with this
new power he cursed midna to Forever
assume the implied form we see her in
for the majority of the game and then
transformed all the remaining Twilight
people into mindless beasts that only
serve him known as The Shadow beasts
after taking care of any potential
pushback from his fellow Twilight he
then set his sights on the world he
wished to conquer the light world with
ganondorf's power he crossed over into
Hyrule and then tasked King boblin to
locate the light Spirits in order to
send Shadow beasts to their locations to
Snuff them out plunge the light into
Twilight and transfer the light
spirits's Tears of Light to the shadow
insects in one Fell Swoop he then took
the remaining Shadow beasts and
powerfully assaulted Hyrule Castle
itself and was greeted with total
surrender from the Hylian ruler Princess
Zelda however eventually Zant remembered
that he has yet to possess the full
power of the ruler of Twilight and
tracks Down Lincoln midna of his own
volition he then asks midna who is the
true ruler of Twilight to join him most
likely implying that he would appreciate
it if she would add her power to his she
refuses this because he's hella creepy
and then Zant proceeds to thrust her
into the light World which for a being
of Twilight that can't exist in the
light is probably something that felt
kind of like a fish being forced to swim
in lava of course Zelda saves midna's
life by sacrificing her Essence and
meanwhile Zant heads off to the
arbiter's grounds to try to break apart
the mirror and prevent the heroic Duo
from hunting him down he even makes an
appearance right before Lincoln midna
head up to the mirror chamber and
revives an ancient stall enemy as a boss
oh what's that you notice I haven't
covered stalard yet keep watching I'll
get to him anyway after which Zan
proceeds to seemingly Retreat back to
the Twilight castle in the realm of
Twilight which ends up being the very
place that he would meet his end after
piecing together the mirror of twilight
link and midna then enter the Twilight
realm and kill Zant once and for all but
not before he was Abe able to confess to
them the true origin of his powers enter
Ganondorf now if you've been a Zelda fan
for a while or if you've watched my
previous Boss video you know why gandorf
Rose to power and all the lore
surrounding his reasons so I'll skip
over his origin story for now however I
will explain what I think happened to
him after link was sent back in time at
the end of Ocarina of Time see most
people know that Ganondorf was captured
and his plans were prevented but there's
a bit more to that story once Ganondorf
was captured he wasn't sentenced to
death immediately according to onuma his
execution at the arbiter's grounds
happened several years after the events
of Ocarina of Time since we can assume
that link warned Zelda and the Hylian
royal family of ganondorf's true
intentions pretty much immediately
following his being sent back in time
which would have directly led to
ganondorf's capture this means that
Ganondorf was most likely imprisoned for
several years before his banishment
where was he imprisoned you ask why at
the arbiter's grounds of course now this
is where things get interesting because
the arbiter's grounds was according to
aru or aru have you say his name the
site where the worst criminals in the
land were held and executed filling the
grounds themselves with their malice now
aru also says that the people who were
sentenced to be executed were instead
sent directly to the underworld aka the
realm of Twilight via the mirror of
twilight but we can tell this is only
half true because those who were
banished were specifically only the
ancient Interlopers as described by
lanairu but that was a long long time
ago there also just happens to be dead
bodies and pose present everywhere
within the arbiter's grounds implying
pretty heavily that there were in fact
inmates who were actually killed here as
well with their malicious Souls haunting
the hallways to this day enter one of
the creepiest bosses in the game the
death blade it's my simplistic personal
interpretation that the deathblade is
literally the malice of the Dead that
aru speaks of Haunting the arbitus
grounds or at least some of it as Lon
Lon historian and I were researching the
blade itself was most likely the
execution blade that was responsible for
taking countless lives of prisoners
leading to the blade itself being
haunted by their combined evil Essences
this also explains why the blade is
being held down to the ground with ropes
covered in what looks to be ofura seals
which are used in several religions such
as Shinto and Buddhism which are present
in Japan and believed to do several
things one of which is sealing Spirits
away on the ground surrounding the blade
is a giant summoning circle with runes
drawn on the inside and only when the
roads attaching the ofuda seals to the
sword are severed the death sword spirit
is released heavily implying that this
room and the blade itself are meant to
trap The Souls of the most malicious
dead inmates within the goat-like spear
that materializes to control the sword
is in my opinion the spirit that the
sword was harboring which is in and of
itself another combination of Poe
Spirits like Bongo Bongo from Ocarina of
Time however this was not the only way
that inmates were executed in the
Arbiters grounds have you ever thought
it was weird that the entire arbiter's
ground setup is built as a Coliseum see
I think this plays into the reasons why
arbiter's grounds has been condemned and
people are now forbidden to even travel
there because what's the point of a
Coliseum combat that normally ends in
merciless gruesome deaths for slaves or
prisoners what if the big dark secret of
the arbiter's grounds isn't just that
there's a goddess ordained banishing
Relic held there or even that inmates
used to be executed there but that the
worst Prisoners the ones who Hyrule
hated the most were sentenced to a
gruesome death by combat against an
insurmountable foe in the midst of the
Coliseum and her Star-Lord the Twilight
fossil now again just like several other
bosses in this video this is just my
theory and you're more than welcome to
believe whichever one you want lots of
fans of the series get caught up trying
to figure out who Star Lord is as in
whether or not Stallard is related to
volvagia or perhaps King dadongo from
Ocarina of Time since they're dinosaurs
and they all share the same boss fight
theme however I personally feel that
this line of thinking is impossible
because this is all assuming that
Stallard is somehow younger than the
aforementioned lizard bosses simply
because Twilight Princess takes place
after Ocarina of Time when all signs
point to the contrary since anuma states
that Twilight Princess takes place
somewhere between 100 and 200 years
after Ocarina of Time and arbiter's
grounds is clearly an ancient rundown
Coliseum that alone implies age of
potentially thousands of years not one
or two hundred given this and the sheer
size of the Colossal Star-Lord himself
and the fact that he was alive long
enough to grow that big and then dead
long enough to completely decompose I'd
wager that Stallard himself is as
ancient if not more ancient than the
arbiter's grounds Coliseum itself
meaning the question isn't really
whether starlord is or is a descendant
of volvagia or the dadongos but rather
whether they are the descendants of
Star-Lord but aside from who Star Lord
is isn't it strange that there's a giant
monster placed right in the middle of an
ancient desert Coliseum isn't it
possible that given the nature of giant
monsters and coliseums and the fact that
the arbiter's grounds was the location
where many prisoners were killed that
Star-Lord himself was used as an
execution method for whoever was in
prison there as in Star-Lord was
execution by combat think about it why
would stalard be placed here in the
center of the grounds directly
underneath the mirror chamber as a guard
for the mirror I heavily doubt that
since Star-Lord was long dead before
Zant Scimitar of Twilight brought him
back back to life and how would Stallard
have even gotten moved inside here in
the first place perhaps the grounds were
built for and around Star-Lord himself
perhaps Stallard is the entire point of
the Coliseum and furthermore what's with
all the style soldiers that stalard can
raise up from the sand at will if you
notice they're all wearing armor but
it's very rudimentary and cheap looking
and not at all like the armor of the
soldiers of Hyrule so it can be assumed
that these non-hylian soldiers were
instead prisoners who were given cheap
equipment to feign the hope that they
could stand in combat against the
terrifying Star-Lord and again as a
reminder this has actually happened in
human history see the history of
Gladiators and the coliseums and
Nintendo draws inspiration from history
time and time again for the Zelda games
the point I'm trying to make though is
that by the time Ganondorf was
imprisoned here within the grounds
prisoners were actually being executed
there either by way of the death sword
quickly or by combat via stalord's
Coliseum chamber and this is also why
the sages attempted to execute Ganondorf
before resorting to banishing him which
is heavily implied with this cutscene to
be something they only do as an absolute
Last Resort so here's a neat little what
if explanation theory for you what if
Ganondorf who was imprisoned for years
and sentenced to death was sentenced to
die at the hands of the monster stalord
and what if Ganondorf was actually the
one prisoner who was able to kill him
perhaps this is even why Ganondorf tells
ant to go resurrect stallord using
ganon's own power he knew where Star
Lord's corpse was because he was the one
who made him a corpse and this led to
the sages taking matters into their own
hands and freaking out a little bit
since Ganondorf killed the big bad
Star-Lord and deciding to execute
Ganondorf personally or you know at
least attempting to but as most people
know this was unsuccessful and Ganondorf
was able to kill the sage of the water
before ultimately being banished out of
the Sage's desperation into the Twilight
realm along with the very same sword of
the sages that was meant to end his life
and once banished within the Twilight
Ganondorf Ganondorf was left bodiness
Ganondorf was left bottomless but alive
and was able to rebuild and recharge his
power while waiting over 100 years for a
suitable host who would help him return
to his beloved Kingdom of Hyrule and
finally claim the throne he so
desperately desired once Zant was denied
the crown and showed his true childish
colors Ganondorf saw the potential for
Zant to be emotionally manipulated and
housed part of his power within Zant
telling him not only to conquer the
Twilight but to also conquer Hyrule
within the light world so that he
himself could return via Zan's new power
after Hyrule has already fallen and once
Ganondorf was able to return to the
light he headed straight for the throne
sealing it off with a powerful Triforce
enabled barrier once he arrived
abandoning his disciples Aunt to fall at
the hands of the Twilight Princess and
this is where he awaited Link in midna's
arrival until the end of the game when
he and Link and midna and Zelda wage an
epic battle against one another that
starts in the throne room and ends in
Hyrule Field where link is finally able
to best him in one-on-one combat using
the skills passed down from the hero
shade who poetically was the first hero
to face the Gerudo King in order to end
Ganondorf once and for all and at the
end of his life when ganroof once again
called upon the power of the Triforce of
power to save him from Death as it did
once before with the sages Zant
strangely pops up on the screen and
cracks his own neck to the side which
seemingly directly results in
ganondorf's actual final death and for a
much more in-depth explanation as to why
Zant popped up here and how his neck
crack possibly ended ganondorf's life
check out the video I made on that exact
topic it'll be linked below along with
all the other theories Twilight Princess
has some of the greatest bosses in the
entire franchise and it was my absolute
pleasure putting this video together for
you guys once again thank you so much
for the awesome turnout on the original
video and thank you for watching this
one and if you'd like for me to continue
with explaining the bosses in the other
Zelda games let me know which ones in
the comments below also let me know if
you learned anything new in this video
and if you would be so kind please
consider liking the video If you enjoyed
it and subscribe if you haven't already
for many more video gaming videos to
come huge things as always to my bandico
of which I have a few amazing new names
to announce say hello to jy8554 who
joined at the top Mast Bandit tier I
mean oh my gosh thank you and say hello
to Jamie p and Debbie B for joining the
ranks as well as all the others who
support the channel every month you guys
are all so amazing and are the reason I
continue to do what I do and that's
about all I've gotten this one so as
always I hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day follow me on my socials and
I'll see you next time this is Bandit
signing out peace
[Music]
thank you
[Music]